So, just to quickly finish up, um,
this is part 4.
In the final part,
um, the greatest problem
that the Ecuadorian healthcare system is suffering now.
And, you know,
I suffer for a long time, um,
but, um, I think particular people are in the.
In the country,
Ecuadorians, um,
and foreign residents,
immigrants, expats,
whatever you want to call them,
are particularly disappointed in this government
under President Lasso,
because, you know,
he promised that there would be
sufficient funding of the healthcare system.
And his vice president is a doctor,
I think, is a neurosurgeon.
So people were looking forward to the
Ecuadorian healthcare system being sufficiently funded,
funded, and that hasn't proven to be true.
Many providers, many practitioners,
doctors as well as nurses, have been let go,
fired, or they haven't been paid.
So there's a shortage of medical professionals,
which, you know,
some extent, at the specialist level is always true,
but it's becoming even more acute.
One thing that means is.
No, no, but there's always general protections.
There's a lot of GPS,
there's a lot of doctors who graduate every year.
It's fairly inexpensive to receive basic treatment here,
which is a positive.
The problem is that you can have.
If you use the public system,
you can have weights as long as a year.
I had to refer patients from my rural health,
my health clinic, and for,
I think it was gastroenterology,
and they were waiting,
you know, 6 months,
8 months a year.
Because there was backup because of the pandemic,
but also because there's a lack of specialist,
and that's in the public health system.
Um, and there's also problem with, um,
a lack of certain medications,
um, even before the pandemic experiences that mean.
The good thing is, generally, if you go to pharmacy here,
you can get almost any medication.
Um, you should.
They should ask for, um,
prescription
that typically don't.
And so medications tend to be cheaper here.
Um, you know, like, I can.
I'm a high blood.
I have high blood pressure.
So you can get like a box of.
And elaborate
for $3. Right.
But there's some medications that
in the public health system,
they're supposed to give you them to you for free,
and they won't have them.
You know, it's.
Sometimes it's
acetaminophen and hope.
Right. So that's a problem in some cases.
But if you have the money,
you can get the medications on your own and.
And so that's a boon.
And so they have antibiotics that are low cost
and they're accessible, unlike the United States.